welcome back everyone it is 6 41 on a
monday and our friend monica is here
with us this morning
monica good morning to you how you doing
hey i'm doing great good morning guys
how are you
hi monica we're good now that you're
here oh how are you doing hello
look i'm feeling real good now got my
new hair on and all of that
all right well hey guys i am happy to be
here today and i'm so happy to introduce
you guys to my next two guests
the hope and relief mission and the
emerald foundation it's the harmony hope
and relief mission and the emerald dream
foundation have partnered to facilitate
charitable giving throughout las vegas
and the state of nevada now man we
hosted
a sisterhood shopping spree for 40
deserving women right here in the las
vegas community
and joining me this morning is lana
fuchs owner of fuchs global venture
capital and tracy smith brand manager
for fuchs global and i got to tell you
these are two
of the most dynamic women i have ever
met when i'm talking
dynamic i mean putting your money where
your mouth is quite literally walking
the walk
these ladies invited me to be a guest
speaker at an amazing valentine's day
event that happened last wednesday good
morning how are you
good morning we're wonderful thanks for
having us
absolutely okay ladies let's talk about
this event 40 women were the recipients
of the big give
talk about the event and what inspired
it
well tracy and i as usual got together
we talked about
what can we do for those women who may
not have significant others in their
lives for valentine's day
and just those that are going through a
hard time especially now
during this covet time everyone's
suffering
and before you know it we came up with
an idea to invite
as many women as we could um obviously
with the coveted restrictions
yeah i wanted 400 but we can only do 40.
and then our luncheon and shopping spree
were
born yeah and tracy a lot of the women
the lady that
right there with holding on to the award
there that's lady die
they have done so much in the community
this woman is fabulous talk about that a
little bit for me
yes so lady died we've been sponsoring
her for a minute she actually takes care
of kids
and um after school programs
um she lets them come over she basically
teaches them
everything that they're not learning at
home yeah yeah so
he helped to facilitate that with her
and she make sure that they eat
they eat uh three times a day especially
now that school is out
right so we just love her spirit she
makes sure that the kids in the
community is always
there doing something with them yeah and
we had to honor her i love it i love it
okay let's get down to the nuts and
bolts here talk about
the emerald dream foundation your
mission here in las vegas and beyond the
las vegas borders because again folks
when i tell you these two ladies
do big things i mean like really big
because all those ladies that you saw in
those pictures
they got a 500 shopping spree all 40 of
them
so they don't just talk go ahead ladies
well the emerald tree foundation was
officially born around 2006 i want to
say
and it started from a very simple idea
arcing one act of random kindness can
change the world
and we really believe that think about
it if one person helped only one other
person
we would be living in a very different
place and so
emerald dream what we do is basically
anything
if there's a need and if it finds us we
fulfill it
it could be a sick animal that needs
help that would pay the vet bills
it could be hungry people the elderly
homeless maybe just someone who is
struggling and is about to be
evicted and so we take care of their
rents and
and some um other bills just to get them
um
back on their feet so to speak yeah
anything absolutely
what people need these days yep and
tracy you know you guys the emerald
dream foundation is partnering with my
charity i'm so excited about this on the
moj show it's called harmony
hope and relief mission now again i know
y'all go big
or you don't go at all so what is the
plan with our two charities partnering
what are we planning
to do here and how big are we gonna go
in the las vegas valley and beyond
we're going big are you kidding me right
now we were lucky enough to expand
this year we are archangels in baltimore
maryland and houston texas
and charlotte north carolina in florida
that would be tampa and florida so you
know what we're gonna do in las vegas oh
yeah absolutely
big okay we're gonna take we're gonna
hit the streets we're gonna take care of
everybody the homeless the elderly
kids people in need like lana says like
we're going to go out there hit the
payments and make it happen
let's make it happen and ladies i got to
wrap but i want to let our viewers know
hey you can contact harmony archangels
by emailing
harmony mojproductions.com once again
that's harmony at mojproductions.com
and i want to tell you this is not my
first time working with lana
and tracy when they say they're going to
change lives these women literally
change lives i have watched them
put money in ziploc bags and i'm not
talking about five or ten dollars
handed out to people in the las vegas
community they hit the ground running
so i'm so happy that harmony is part of
it harmony archangels ladies thank you
so much i appreciate you joining me this
morning
thank you have a wonderful day thank you
so much all right and don't forget to
catch my moj show facebook
live weeknights at 7 p.m and
sheri like i said these women i have
watched them change people's lives by
helping them move from one place to
another giving them
money uh taking kids and families on
shopping sprees getting new jobs for
people
lana fuchs and tracy baltimore are two
of the most
dynamic women and i'm so happy to be
working with them you bet and hats off
to them it's one thing to talk about the
other thing to do it absolutely so
thank you for bringing those ladies to
us today monica absolutely for sure